بين زلزله
وثلاثه وعشرين مفارقه الحزن الممزوج
بالغضب في الشارع التركي او صلاح حزب
العداله والتنميه للسلطه بعد زلزال 99
المشاعر ذاتها قد تقلص من فرص استمراره في
الحكم في
1999 قدم الحزب وعودا ضخمه للاتراك
الغاضبين ستكون هناك قوانين بناء اكثر
صرامه وهو ما حدث بالفعل بعدما تولى
السلطه لكنها بقت مجرد قوانين لم تنفذ على
ارض الواقع او في الكثير من المناطق فكيف
تتم عمليه البناء في تركيا
بسهوله يحصل المقاولون على تراخيص البناء
وبعد استكمال عمليه البناء يجب الحصول على
ترخيص الاشغال شهاده تؤكد ان المبنى صالح
للاستخدام اين تكمن المشكله في التنفيذ
والرقابه الحصول على تصاريح البناء سهل
كما قلنا لكن عمليات تفتيش ضعيفه اذا كانت
المعايير تفرض استخدام 100 طن من الحديد
في مبنى فسيستخدمون 90 طن هكذا وصف مقاول
سابق الوضع للاكون على سبيل المثال بعد
مغادره المفتشين لموقع البناء يقلل
المقاولون من كميه او جوده الحديد
المستخدم ثم يدخلون يدخلون في مفاوضات غير
رسميه مع السلطات المحليه على امل الحصول
على عفو ودفع غرامه وطبعا النتيجه كارثيه
والمثال رايناه في الزلزال الاخير نحو 10%
من المباني المدمره بنيه الظاهريه وفقا
للمعايير الجديده
الصارمه لا مفر من المقارنات مع الزلزال
1999 واستخدامه كمرجع عند مسائله الشعب
للحكومه كان امامكم 24 24 عاما للاستعدادي
لهذه اللحظه هكذا المعارضه استغلال
الكارثه السياسيا الحكومه التي اعتقلت عدد
من المقاولين بعد الزلزال لكن السؤال من
الذي رخص هذه البنايات تنتقد الحكومه
اليوم تنتقد على برنامج عفو الشامل على
2018 سمح للمباني منخفضه الجوده والتي لم
تلتزم بمعايير السلامه بدفع غرامه ماليه
فقط نظير المخالفات وبالمناسبه القرارات
اطلقت منذ اربعينيات القرن الماضي
نيمارشيوس
[موسيقى]
ك
نيمارتها وتند
يرى مهندسونا اتراك ان منح المباني التي
انتهكت قواعد السلامه الصفه القانونيه ومن
بنها 75 الف مبنى في منطقه الزلزال فقط
يرونه يعني تجاوز شديد انتقاد اخر
للمعارضه بعد زلزال 1999 فرضت الدوله
ضريبه لتستخدم عائداتها لتستخدم عائداتها
في الاستعداد للزلزال والزلازل القادمه
اليوم الاتراك يتساءلون فيما استثمرت
ضرائب الزلزال وهل يمتلك عمله هاتاي اجابه
مثلا
بري المسؤوليه فاحزابها تدير عددا كبيرا
من بلديات المدن المتضرره كما انها دعمت
قرار برنامج العفو عن البناء في 2018 لنفس
الاسباب التي اقرها حزب اردوغان حزب
العداله والتنميه اسباب انتخابيه انتقاد
اخر لاردوغان ولحكومته بسبب تغيير قانون
ليصبح الجيش اليوم في انتظار تعليمات قبل
التدخل على عكس زلزال 1999 هنا اصبح الجيش
في مواقع البحث خلال ساعات لكن في المقابل
هناك حقائق قد تدعم اردوغان واقف وافق على
المساعده الدوليه فورا وسهل من عملياتها
على عكس الزلزال 1999 الذي رفض فيه
التحالف الحاكم مشاركه فرق انقاذ اجنبيه